I think I've been very good at position
myself to not get my heart broken but I
have to be vulnerable in order to in
order for it to work in order to fall in
love so I had a serious girlfriend a few
years ago mm-hmm
so I think I made a lot of mistakes as
far as like putting things ahead of like
that relationship and like insecurities
and like who I was and where my career
was at and where I thought I should be
the person I thought I should be and so
that affected a lot like the person I
was in that relationship right so I've
been like really careful in the past
couple years and I noticed myself like
being careful with you last season I was
the same way I didn't open up till five
weeks in and you know it took me a long
time so I get if that's how you are but
I'm so like open and excited about you
that I want to start developing our
relationship yeah yeah like it just it
means a lot to me to be in a situation
where I'm like so attracted to you and
when I'm around you I have a feeling I
haven't had in a really long time and
it's scary but it's also the best thing
that I wake up to every morning and like
knowing how important like just the word
love is to me and like it's like I've
said that to one person my entire life I
said my family
you